leaving as fast as they can people fled
the northeastern city of sumi trying to
get out before nightfall when a
ceasefire ends
the night before airstrikes hit
residential buildings and a power plant
local authorities said 21 people were
killed
further west people fleeing the city of
erpine close to the capital kiev
crossing a damaged bridge that russian
troops have repeatedly fired on as
civilians tried to get across
heartbreaking goodbyes as many of the
men split up from their families to go
back and fight
others helping those unable to make the
journey by themselves
she is barely walking but we are doing
our best thank you
it is good that we could cross the
bridge
bombs are exploding over there quite
intense
is totally damaged
meanwhile in the capitol
president volody miyazalenski refusing
to flee
a video message to his people trying to
prepare them for the days to come
snow is falling
this is spring
the war is the same as spring
severe
but it will be all right
we will win anyway
military analysts say the russian
onslaught will likely get worse in the
coming days russian forces are
increasingly turning to shelling
civilian areas and infrastructure
while their tanks and troops are bogged
down outside key cities
in the port city of odessa residents are
mounting barricades in front of the
beloved opera house
so far the city hasn't been hit
but if the experience of the last
several days is any guide
anyone who stays behind should be
prepared for the worst
let's go to dw correspondent nick
connolly who is reporting for us from
the ukrainian capital kyiv nick the
humanitarian situation around kiev is
getting worse how refugees been able to
get to the capital so that they can then
travel on outside of ukraine
that definitely is happening even though
it is very difficult we have seen people
lose their lives trying to get out of
those western suburbs of kiev so
slightly counterintuitively people now
trying to get west to the eu to poland
are having to travel east out of those
suburbs into kiev to get on a train
because the train uh connections the
train tracks have been destroyed around
european so they're going in buses the
main highway leading west that is near
it being is also pretty dangerous
there's been a lot of military activity
along there people hearing shots fired
traveling so basically they have to go
by kind of side routes back into the
capital then head out south westerly
direction away from the fighting we saw
pretty extraordinary scenes at the train
station yesterday announcements on the
loudspeaker of lost children looking for
their parents people traveling with
their pets uh people in wheelchairs
trying to get around a station which
unfortunately it was overfilled with
humanity but also some of the lifts were
out of service so people trying to carry
them upsteps um it is an exodus
as as the united nations has said this
is the biggest refugee movement in
europe since the second world war so
it's pretty difficult to look at and to
you know to talk to these people without
feeling
just kind of at a loss is what to say
but people are still making their way
out and they are still able to get out
for now kiev has not yet been encircled
if you tell us what life is like for
those who have decided to stay in kiev
well for now in downtown cuba where i am
now
there's electricity they're still uh
heating they're still mobile phone
networks so that makes life bearable and
there are definitely more people here
than you would think if you walk around
the streets pretty empty apart from
journalists and soldiers and the
occasional person walking a dog or going
to supermarket we were out in the
suburbs today not far from european uh
slightly further south in an area where
the local territorial defense forces are
preparing for a russian onslaught where
they've blown up bridges where they have
tried to kind of block the roads in a
way to prevent tanks moving across
they're pretty worried that the russians
are going to build pontoon bridges and
try and
overwhelm their attempts to stop this
happening but it was kind of
extraordinary to see the kind of
range of people now in uniform bearing
arms you had someone who
usually takes high school kids on
mountain hiking trips you had
i.t people you had people who work
managing supermarkets all these people
are now suddenly in boots in uniforms
with a gun on their shoulder at
checkpoints trying to look for russian
sleeper agents or to stop
looting happening and it's kind of
extraordinary scene to people who would
in normal life have never come across
each other now suddenly united by this
danger to their homes
and ukrainian president zielinski is
continuing his efforts to shore up
support from western countries how
optimistic is he that his demands are
being met
well certainly the sanctions against
russia in the last few weeks have been
unprecedented i think they definitely
took the russian leadership by surprise
especially the freezing of those russian
central bank assets so basically that
war chest that russia had built up over
the previous years especially for a case
like this to basically um kind of
cushion the effect of sanctions that was
basically made
useless by those freezing uh sanctions
from western uh banks i think though the
the the real crunch now will be if is if
western countries that say they support
ukraine's democracy are they really
willing to pay an economic price for
this are they willing to pay a lot more
for energy by you know not buying
russian oil and gas are they willing to
go there are they willing to risk
further confrontation with russia russia
has basically uh threatened the west
with nuclear war in recent days and
we've seen lots of western governments
kind of rolling back on their promises
of support for ukraine there's a real
worry here in here whether these western
countries are actually going to make
good on those promises and be willing to
pay a price to support ukraine
dw correspondent nick connolly thank you
so much for your reporting from keith
let's go now to pavel felgenhauer a
moscow-based military analyst thank you
so much for joining us on the show i
want to ask you almost two weeks into
the war and we are seeing russia's
territorial gains especially in the
south and east of the country
whereas in the north and around kiev the
operation seems to not be going at full
speed can you tell us why that is
uh well the russian offensive
reached a kind of crescent i would but
actually it's stopped all over the place
there's russia still has the initiative
it's trying to push in different
directions in the zoom
that's trying to close in from the other
side to
uh into the uh uganda's oblast
and also in the south there's still
offensive action but there it's also
kind of right now
stopped the russian offensive
effectively has ran out of steam
and what are we to make of that serious
problem
well that's because russia doesn't have
apparently sufficient reserves
uh russia threw into battle more or less
what it could
russia right now has a
rather big
uh regular standing army
we didn't have such an army since the
crimean war in the mid 19th century it's
an army can go into war without
mobilization of reserves
uh the official figure the last official
figure
that was appeared in
last august
was
um defense minister sergey shoigu who
said that we have 168
permanent ready
battalion tactical groups that's a lot
native deployed against russia for
tactical battalion groups one in each
baltic state one and poland so russia
has more
and over a hundred went into ukraine
so russia kind of theoretically still
has i don't know 40 60 50
left
50 maybe but it can't send them all in
you have to keep garrisons in the
kuril islands and chukotka and many i in
the in cohenion grant of course
against the baltic states and against
poland and
belarus so that means russia has ran out
of reserves because fish will have
reserves but actually they're not
reserves they're just on paper because
these were people who served one year in
the armed forces compulsory and were
never called up for retraining you if
you even call them in that would mean
they have to train the fort waste at
three months maybe more before you can
send them into battle right but given
the resources that ukraine has so i just
want to jump in because also from
ukraine's side um how long do you think
keith can realistically keep up its
resistance against this
well the problem the thing is for the
russian problem is
that ukraine began a
mobilization officially it's a
full mobilization of the reserve and
they have
a lot of reservists who served in the
eight years of the contract in the
donbass against the russians
and they're calling them up there's also
volunteers of the territorial defense
so
russian frontline positions and russian
frontline forces are more or less static
and they are even getting weaker
as the attrition continues well
ukrainians are getting stronger day by
day
reservists are called up
the uh ukrainian army stopped the
russian offensive they didn't capture
that much territory so
ukrainian ukraine controls the territory
they have their line uh their chain of
command is intact
organized resistance continues and
they're organizing uh mobilization they
didn't
have
i'm sorry to jump in but we do have to
leave the interview there i want to
thank you again for coming on to dw news
thanks so much for taking the time
thank you
and ukrainian president vladimir
zelinski has addressed british members
of parliament in the house of commons in
london zelensky received a standing
ovation from mps as he spoke to them via
a video link from kiev where he remains
despite increasing russian pressure on
the capital
we spoke about the hardships endured by
civilians but said his people would
fight to ensure they do not lose their
country
the ukrainian leader appealed to britain
and the west to do more to help his
country
please increase the pressure of
sanctions
against this
country and please recognize this
country as a terrorist state
and please make sure that our ukrainian
skies are safe
please make sure
that
you do
what needs to be done
and
what is stipulated by the greatness of
your country
and let's bring in dw correspondent
charlotte chelsea pill in london for
more charlotte what stood out to you
about zielinski's speech to lawmakers
well it was an extremely emotive speech
that was given earlier this evening he
really day by day went through what 13
days of war have meant for ukraine some
of the horrors that he described having
been endured saying that this was a war
that he did not start now he compared
ukraine's fights to the british fight
against the nazis in the second world
war and in doing so
he echoed comments made by former
british prime minister winston churchill
during that second war in a very famous
speech that will be known to the british
public and many around the world he was
saying will not give up we will fight
whatever the costs in the forest the
fields the shores and the streets he
also uh quoted the uh william
shakespeare in this speech too uh he
said the question that's faced ukraine
is to be or not to be and he said
tonight he can say ukraine will be he
also addressed the british prime
minister boris johnson directly he asked
for even more sanctions to be imposed
and he also
asked that the ukrainian skies are kept
safe a reference there to his repeated
plea for a no-fly zone something that
the uk alongside many others has
repeatedly uh defied
so he clearly knows his audience there
um what has the reaction been to his
address
there was a standing ovation from
parliamentarians both before and after
that speech absolutely packed house and
just to really stress the significance
of this this is the first time that a
foreign leader albeit virtually has
addressed the house of commons in that
chamber like this so people have been
describing it here as a historic moment
prime minister boris johnson immediately
afterwards responded he said nero is the
house listened to such an address he
said it's moved the hearts of everyone
in this house he stressed that the uk is
determined to press on to tighten the
pressure on russia
thank you very much for that charlotte
chelsea pill our correspondent in london
let's give the united states now where
president joe biden has announced a ban
on imports of russian oil into the
country he said americans don't want to
subsidize vladimir putin's war in
ukraine despite rising costs at the gas
station
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
this is a move that has strong
bipartisan support the congress and i
believe in the country
so for more i'm joined by dw's economic
journalist chelsea delaney hi chelsea um
so the u.s has banned imports of russian
oil to put pressure on putin what are
the chances that european countries are
going to follow suit well i think it's
important to keep in mind that the u.s
and europe are really in very different
positions here the u.s uh imported
about three but about three percent of
the us's oil imports last year were from
russia and the eu that's 27
so the eu is is drastically more
dependent on russian oil also russian
gas so they're obviously much more
reluctant to actually get uh to to go
forward with this and we saw this from
biden in his announcement today he said
that we recognize that not all of our
allies and partners are in a position to
join us so he does sort of know that
europe is in a different position i
think it does put more pressure on the
eu to speed up their acceleration of
of getting rid of russian oil and gas
but for now what we've heard from
leaders here you know in germany analina
bauerbach saying today the foreign
minister that this would bring transport
to a halt so there's still a lot of
reluctance in europe to pull that lever
right so given those quite severe
potential consequences i mean are there
other countries that are in a position
uh to step up and replace the energy
needs that russia has been supplying
yeah that's a huge question russia
obviously one of the biggest suppliers
of oil and gas in the world
everyone's asking now who's who can do
that who can fill that gap really there
isn't enough oil there isn't enough gas
out there to do that it's what analysts
are saying there are other countries
that could increase oil production of
course we have the opec plus global oil
alliance they uh countries like saudi
arabia where the united arab emirates do
have potential to increase oil
production but i think what we've seen
on the market it shows us that there
really
isn't enough oil out there we've seen
prices you know up to 130 dollars a
barrel also in the gas market it's going
to be extremely difficult for uh for gas
suppliers to increase their production
particularly here in the eu we get most
of our gas from pipelines
there is the potential to get lng
liquefied natural gas from ships but um
countries like um like qatar and in the
us are are trying to increase the
production but it's a very slow slow
process so that's why we're seeing the
eu
really put forward these plans to to
reduce their dependency on uh on russian
energy but they're saying it's going to
take really until 2030 until they're
fully able to get that out of the mix
and if you can put this into lay terms
what is a normal person going about
their daily life going to experience as
a result of this yeah it has huge
implications energy prices are not
abstract we feel them all in our daily
lives uh for people who drive cars
already this is having a huge impact
here in europe we've seen gas prices
petrol prices rise above eight dollars
in some places
in the us it's about four dollars these
are all new records we're really in
uncharted territory and also you have to
remember that we came into this year
already seeing inflation at multi-decade
highs so that's definitely going to add
to those problems as well you have
electricity prices heating prices really
going to skyrocket for a lot of
households so of course this is going to
hit the most vulnerable the hardest
all right dw's chelsea delaney thank you
so much for joining me in the studio
with that update